every single song you know with stevie
wonder i ended up cooking with him for
like a week before i got him to do
harmonica yeah when you say you were
cooking with stevie wonder for a week
yeah that's crazy so you're in this like
i'm in the studio with him in person
hanging out with stevie hanging out
getting the real gems the real knowledge
they don't make them like him anymore
wow this is michael his stories that he
got about like
your icons icon you know wow like it's
just the most um unimaginable thing man
like for he talks about like
obama pulling up on him at the studio
like before he was president
you know like his story is just
different bro no he's talking about
little mike you know like yeah i
remember one time i was in there
bro what was the little mike story jesus
it wasn't he just brings up like small
like things like like he's michael
jackson's big homie that's so crazy you
gotta think that this is michael
jackson's big homie and now he's your
big homie
good company virgo connection was he
like um just a fan of yours like like
that's a you know what's crazy because
i've seen stevie wonder pop out
before um i want to say at an anderson
pack show oh adult but he's out like you
i've seen stevie wonder three or four
times like at random [ __ ] and i'll just
be like
yeah he's living life bro he's living he
lived a good life but he he just was up
on like like how did that happen like so
somebody from his team reached out to um
somebody on my team to dallas i believe
shout out to dallas and they was like um
yo like stevie want to like lock in with
corday and i was like what done deal
done so i pulled up on him and we just
started uh he had me work on the record
for his
and um
blase blaso we working on this uh can't
put in the hands of faith we're working
on his record and um like day two or
three he's like yo if you want me um
something on your album
then uh i got you and i'm like i had my
laptop and my hard drive with me like
say less i thought yo can i get you to
play harmonica on this because i like
using people's like almost
if you know stevie wonder you know him
playing harmonica isn't a hidden talent
right but to like the average music
person they may not know him playing
harmonica same with like j cole getting
him to produce on him to make a beat you
know like i like using people's hidden
talents and and and highlighting them
and so i say that to say um yeah just
locking in with him like it's crazy like
he just matter of fact he called me
today to album job he facetimed me
and um yeah it's about i'm not even
trying to speak in my truth that's
amazing speaking
it's an interesting way for stevie
wonder to call somebody it's facetime he
uses it pretty adept i didn't believe he
was blind when i first met him i feel
like when you he's been as blind as he's
been like i've as long as he's just been
for sure he knows how to make news he
knows yeah for sure he's definitely
blind by the way but
um he's like super it's not a crutch for
him it's just like daredevil kind of
like you watching daredevil on netflix
you're like this guy is not blind like
yeah no he's just a dad he's been
blindfolded he's 70 years old i don't
know when he went blind but he's been
blind for a long time it probably also
helps that he was once not blind and
he's a rich blind man rich blind like
super rich if you're going to be blind
you might you got to be rich blind so
it's like it's so much probably like and
mind you this is just like
me inferring me guessing it's probably
like so much technology he has like
access to to make him being blind like
super easy because he's just like filthy
rich you know
for real so shout out to stevie wonder
i'm sure